avec benoît martin secrétaire général de
la cgt paris bonsoir benoît martin merci
de répondre à nos questions en direct
sur arte france comment est-ce que vous
acquiescez les instructions publiées par
le comité des droits de l'homme de l'onu
écoutez moi je porte un avis tout à fait
positif c'est extrêmement intéressant
cet avis juridique de l'union de l'onu
c'est une réaffirmation du droit
international par le fait de dire et de
redire que le droit de réunion pacifique
1 constitue le fondement même d'une
société démocratique
c'est tout à fait le bienvenu dans cette
période troublée ans de crises
sanitaires de crise démocratique un peu
partout dans le monde et on a bien vu
par exemple avec le mouvement black
l'armateur que ça s'est étendu comme une
traînée de poudre un peu partout dans le
monde il ya eu des mobilisations est
compris dans des des endroits où s'était
pas vraiment autorisé de se réunir mais
ça ça c'est quand même fou et et donc
les manifestants général ou conscience
de la nécessité d'appliquer les gestes
d'arrière avant qu'il faut concilier le
droit de se réunir de manifester avec
les précautions sanitaires
est ce que ces instructions est ce
qu'elles ont un côté contraignant est ce
qu'elles vont être entendus appliquées
par les états ou bien est ce que ce ne
sont finalement que des recommandations
c'est un avis juridique qui pourraient
être mobilisées en cas de saisine d'une
juridiction parade en psy de mal à la
cgt saisir les juridictions compétentes
par rapport à droit de manifester qui
aurait été restreints et bien le juge
pourra et nous dans notre dans notre
truc plaidoiries à nous pourrions
mobiliser cet avis juridiques de l'onu
et une sangle dur ou sans nul doute ça
pourrait compter par contre il n'ya pas
de convenir de l'application automatique
le gouvernement par exemple français va
tenir
prendre acte a effectivement de cet avis
juridique mais il ne va pas forcément le
mettre en oeuvre
automatiquement le comité souligne
également le droit des journalistes et
des observateurs des associations de
défense des droits de l'homme à couvrir
à documenter les rassemblements y
compris ceux qui sont interdits et
violent cette crise sanitaire mondiale
est ce qu elle soulève finalement un
problème de liberté de la presse à
travers le monde ah oui et également on
a bien vu ces derniers temps aux états
unis mais par exemple également suscité
mon compte mais on peut citer paris
aussi voilà donc ces derniéres années
notamment depuis deux soirées que
mouvement ddj les journaux on a bien vu
que par choix rangs des journalistes en
se voyait entravé dans l'exercice de
leur mission d'information du matériel a
été cassé des journalistes ont été
parfois molesté ont pris dans des
événements qui les dépassait totalement
est dû à des violences policières
et c'est tellement de reparler de ces
violences policières en ce moment
beaucoup de gens site max weber vous
savez sociologues parlent de la daf il
la violence légitime a le monopole de la
violence légitime qu'exerce l'état mais
faut pas faire dire non plus à webber ce
qu'il n'a pas dit à ce qui est légitime
et puis avoir une légitime défense des
policiers dans certaines circonstances
mais les forces de l'ordre ne doivent
pas faire tout et n'importe quoi voilà
on est dans un état de droit donc vous
comme moi comme ce maquereau comme un
policier - jordan ne peuvent pas être
violent lorsqu'il voilà ce qui est une
règle générale de droit commun alors les
policiers les gendarmes peuvent l'être
dans certains cas peuvent faire usage de
la force mais il faut que ce soit
justifié
en vertu de circonstances particulières
ont donc ces derniers temps ça a été
vraiment on a stipulé à gérald darmanin
hier ben oui monsieur darmana oui oui
d'ailleurs il n'est pas du tout bien
venu lui
au ministère de l'intérieur par rapport
à son comportement par rapport à des
femmes notamment
mais voilà je voulais dire que
effectivement présents sur vincent saint
leu concernera oui mais ça c'est comme
lorsque intro cette année en vendant
l'effective mende et les magistrats
appliquent ce principe extrêmement
important de notre exemple son innocence
mais nous séduire la société lorsqu'on
sera dans nos permanences des femmes et
qui ont subi des violences
on les croit pour revenir sur le sujet
de l'onu le comité des droits de l'homme
de l'onu je cite les motifs généraux
comme l'ordre public ou la sécurité
publique ne constituent pas des bases
solides pour interdire des
rassemblements pacifiques mais si le
nombre de contamination augmente
sensiblement après une manifestation à
ce qu'il y'a pas un problème à ce moment
là est ce que le droit de manifester est
plus fort que l'enjeu de santé publique
l'enjeu de santé publique peut être
relevé par une pleine transparence dans
l'information et une pleine démocratie
donc voilà ous avons un tout les projets
du gouvernement un qui veut continuer à
réformer des réformes néolibérales donc
ils sont prêts à tout pour restreindre
les crédits relais des résistances 1 qui
pourraient se former et y compris
utiliser la question sanitaire comme
prétexte pour pour restreindre des
droits de manifester donc moi je peux
vous dire que demain à paris aura une
manifestation de jeunes migrants un
mineur qui sont totalement livrés à
eux-mêmes donc il ya un certain nombre
d'organisations dans la cgt on va les
soutenir
d'autres manifestations ont eu lieu y
compris des mines et des manifestation
contre les violences policières à
caractère raciste et donc ce soit à fait
malvenu de réprimer
mouvement social dans son ensemble merci
benoît martin d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la cgt paris